she's having the time of her life while
lowering her A1C but the actress from
the jardians commercial has a much
bigger story to tell about her life in
Showbiz one of the most ubiquitous
commercials on TV right now is for the
prescription drug jardance it's designed
to help people with type 2 diabetes keep
their blood sugar levels under control
but you probably know it better for its
elaborate song and dance routine with an
actress enthusiastically extolling its
virtues the commercial has generated
quite a bit of Buzz especially among
viewers who are curious about who
exactly its star performer is her name
is Deanna cologne and she's no stranger
to show business and this definitely
isn't her first time on TV as she was a
contestant on America's Got Talent back
in 2013. during her run on the
competition show cologne blew the judges
away when she auditioned with a
rendition of and I am telling you I'm
not going from the musical Dream Girls
she ultimately made it to the quarter
semi-finals before being eliminated but
that was just the beginning of her
career the same year that she appeared
on AGT she also booked an extensive ad
campaign for Big Lots on top of all that
she's assembled numerous soundtrack and
music department credits on TV shows and
films
since I was like seven or eight I used
to be in my basement singing along with
Whitney Houston and Mariah Carey records
Deanna colon actually got her start in
Showbiz under the name Deanna de la
Chapa which is what she went by during
her time on America's Got Talent she's
been a prolific performer in commercials
for years with many of them
incorporating music as that is her
specialty and a look at her IMDb reveals
many additional credits behind the
camera as she's contributed music to
such shows as Sex In The City the hills
and the league just to name a few
outside of commercials cologne's acting
credits are much less numerous with just
one listed on IMDb as she appeared on a
2021 episode of the TBS Anthology comedy
series miracle workers with all the
attention that her jardiance commercial
has been getting it's certainly possible
that we'll be seeing more of cologne on
our screens in the future and if her
music work continues along at the same
Pace we could very well hear her or
music composed by her without even
realizing it based on this trajectory it
seems like cologne's clout in the
entertainment industry is only growing
on her Instagram she recently confirmed
that she's the voice behind the song in
one of instacart's most popular ads
while she can't be seen in the
commercial which has over 1 million
views on YouTube we can't hear her
distinctive voice bring the ad to life
we have a feeling that she'll eventually
be fondly remembered for more than just
Guardians in addition to working on some
of the TV world's most popular shows and
commercials cologne also works as a
vocal coach and she boasts quite the
prestigious background as she graduated
from the iconic Berkeley College of
Music she originally emerged from humble
beginnings but her time at Berkeley
afforded her some significant
opportunities as she revealed in a 2020
interview with Voyage La during her time
at Berkeley she won her first national
singing jingles and also sing for iconic
musicians like Diana Ross and Patti
LaBelle cologne had to break some
barriers to become successful and now
she's at a point in her career where she
can say that she's quite proud of
herself as she declares to Voyage la I
truly feel there is nothing I cannot do
cologne's story is the kind that shows
just what you can accomplish with enough
hard work in addition to all of her
acting and singing work she's also a
popular Creator on social media as she
boasts nearly 300 000 followers on tick
tock
foreign